One hundred years ago, a reclusive Czech-Jew
living anonymously amid Prague’s spires
managed to change the way we see the world.
He was the son of a shopkeeper, an insurance
lawyer by trade.
Outwardly, he appeared sickly, forgettable.
But inside?
Inside, this sallow young man’s mind was
alive: with visions of horror, with paranoia,
existential dread, and alienation.
Working at night, he took those visions and
etched them onto paper, creating fiction unlike
anything ever seen before.
That young man’s name was Franz Kafka.
And his work would shape the entire 20th Century.
Born into a German-speaking family in the
Austro-Hungarian Empire, Kafka spent his whole
life suffering from illness and anxiety.
He was miserable at home, unlucky in love,
and too depressed to function anywhere but
in his insurance office.
Yet he made up for this by having a mind so
strange, so inventive that today he’s arguably
Europe’s most famous author.
Join us as we delve inside the work of Franz
Kafka, and the awful life that made it all
possible.
Early Years: In the Penal Colony
It was a hot July day in 1883 when Hermann
Kafka became a father for the first time.
A Prague shopkeeper from a working class Jewish
family, Hermann was a man who’d fought all
his life to get where he was.
His battle had been a tough one.
1883 was the era of the Austro-Hungarian Empire,
when Prague was dominated by Germans, and
Jews were at a constant disadvantage.
Through the sheer force of his gigantic, volatile
personality, Hermann had managed to take a
little clothing shop and turn it into a bustling
store.
He’d bought a fancy house, found an educated
wife, even broken into the closed world of
the German elites.
And now his first son had arrived.
The son who was going to be as sporty, as
commanding, as powerful, and as straightforwardly
Germanic as his old man affected to be.
It’s likely that, as Hermann took baby Franz
Kafka into his arms for the first time, he
felt a rush of pride.
If he did, it was the last time he ever felt
anything but contempt for his son.
From the earliest age, it was obvious that
Franz Kafka was not the stout, hearty man
Hermann wanted him to be.
The boy was small, sickly.
He was troubled by boils, and afflicted with
melancholy.
From Hermann’s perspective, this was a little
like opening a box you think is going to contain
a delicious cake, only to discover it instead
contains bitter disappointment.
But from Franz Kafka’s perspective, it was
like being born into a world where everything
you did was doomed to end in humiliation.
Hermann was an angry man at the best of times,
but something about his ineffectual son seems
to have actively offended him.
He would explode at young Kafka for no reason.
Belittle him endlessly for being useless,
pathetic, a failure of a human.
Perhaps its not surprising that, by the time
Kafka started school, his self-esteem was
in the gutter.
Still, while he may have done everything in
his power to destroy his son’s confidence
at home, Hermann was still, at heart, a social
climber.
That meant making sure that, outwardly, Kafka
appeared to have every advantage in life.
As Hermann’s business boomed, he began sending
Kafka to the elite Altstädter Staatsgymnasium,
having one of the family’s Czech servants
walk the lad there every morning.
For the working class Jew, it must’ve been
a whole peacock’s worth of feathers in his
cap to send his boy somewhere so prestigious.
But for his shy, miserable son, it was simply
Hell.
Kafka hated the school.
Absolutely hated it.
While he did well academically, he found the
place authoritarian, dehumanizing, alienating.
It was around this time that a black parasite
first began to tunnel its way into the boy’s
brain.
That parasite was what we’d today call a
serious anxiety disorder.
One that made Kafka constantly feel like there
was a ball of wire at the center of his body,
winding ever tighter.
If you’ve ever suffered from anxiety, you’ll
know that “suffering” is the exact right
term to use.
Well Franz Kafka would suffer from it for
the rest of his life.
However, the boy’s teenage years weren’t
all bad news.
Between the emotional abuse at home and his
miserable life at school, Kafka needed an
outlet, somewhere he could escape to.
A warm burrow he could hide in.
It was at this time that the boy started writing.
Description of a Struggle
Come 1902, Franz Kafka was studying law at
Charles University, and writing on the side.
He’d actually wanted to study chemistry,
but had switched to law after two weeks when
Hermann pressured him, because law would look
better to the family’s middle class friends.
And with his son already a self-declared atheist
and socialist, Hermann desperately needed
a new feather for his suddenly bedraggled-looking
cap.
Yet even with his father still controlling
his life at university, Kafka managed to eke
out some space for himself.
He joined Lese und Redehalle der Deutschen
Studenten, a literary club for German speakers.
While at this club, he met the man who would
one day come to define Kafka’s legacy.
That man was Max Brod.
Born about a year after Kafka, Max Brod was
an outgoing Jewish intellectual who was charming,
creative, intelligent, and everything Kafka
felt he himself was not.
Nonetheless, the two hit it off, forming their
own little clique.
It would be this close friendship that later
saved Kafka’s writing from the ashes.
But not yet.
Brod and Kafka were both just students at
this time, a long way from actually publishing
their stories.
So when Kafka finally graduated in June, 1906,
it was not into a life of writing and plumbing
the depths of the human soul, but into a life
of working as an unpaid clerk for the local
courts.
To say Kafka found this job crushingly dull
would be to overestimate how exciting it was.
The work left him cranky, depressed, and lethargic.
Worse, he was still living at home, still
dealing with Hermann’s volcanic temper and
tiny cruelties.
His only solace was that soon it would be
over.
Soon, Kafka would have enough experience to
join an international office, one that would
send him abroad, away from his father.
In October, 1907, Kafka finally signed up
with an Italian insurance company, fully expecting
to be sent down to Italy at any day.
Instead, he found himself stuck in a Prague
office, dealing with suffocating bureaucracy,
unpaid overtime, and brutal hours that left
him too exhausted to write.
By the time Kafka finally resigned, his dream
of living abroad had been crushed.
Instead, he meekly resigned himself to staying
at home, to living in Prague and sharing a
house with Hermann, to living with his father’s
constant putdowns.
In August, 1908, Kafka began his new job at
the Worker’s Accident Insurance Institute
in the shadow of Prague Castle.
He would stay there for the rest of his working
life.
But even as Kafka’s dream of leaving his
abuser far behind faded into distant memory,
he began to nurture another.
Kafka’s new job finished in the mid-afternoon.
If he slept after it finished, that meant
he could wake up after dark and spend most
of the night writing.
Kafka would later say this routine felt less
like a calling or a hobby than a form of communion.
Maybe even a penance, with writing being the
only way he could atone for the sins he was
convinced filled his stick-thin body.
That same year, Max Brod convinced Kafka to
publish his first stories.
Although they sold poorly, the critical reaction
was good enough to convince Kafka to keep
writing.
The Metamorphosis
In August, 1912, Kafka arrived at a dinner
party in Max Brod’s home to find his friend
had an unexpected guest.
It was now four years since Kafka had published
his first collection of stories, and he was
waist deep in the novel that would later become
Amerika, AKA The Man Who Disappeared.
But that night, literature was the furthest
thing from Kafka’s mind.
He was too busy thinking about the woman sat
opposite him.
Felice Bauer was one of those “friends of
a friend of a cousin” types that the gregarious
Brod would invite to his home, a woman who
usually lived in Berlin but was visiting Prague.
In his diary, Kafka would later write that
she had a:
“bony, empty face that wore its emptiness
openly.
Bare throat.
A blouse thrown on...
Almost broken nose.
Blonde, somewhat straight, unattractive hair,
strong chin.
As I was taking my seat I looked at her closely
for the first time, by the time I was seated
I already had an unshakeable opinion.”
That unshakeable opinion was that he was in
love.
This being Franz Kafka, the courtship that
started that summer evening wasn’t exactly
conventional.
He waited until Felice Bauer had gone back
to Berlin before telling her of his feelings
via letter.
From then on, the two were writing to one
another two times a day.
Or Kafka was, at any rate.
For her part, Bauer seems to have been flattered,
but maybe not quite to the extent of writing
long, heart-rending letters every few hours.
Still, her effect on the writer was palpable.
Not six weeks after they’d met, Kafka sat
down one evening at his desk overlooking the
Vltava River.
By the time he got up again, it was dawn,
his legs were in agony, and he’d just finished
his first masterpiece.
The Judgement is a hard tale to describe,
in that it’s a typically Kafka short story
without an easy meaning.
The basic plot is that a young man goes to
tend to his sick father.
But as the tale progresses, the father grows
in stature and power until, like some terrible,
tyrant king, he rises from his bed and condemns
the young man to death by drowning.
The man immediately goes and throws himself
into the Vltava.
Gee, we wonder where your son got the inspiration
for that tale, Hermann.
Yet if the tale sounds slight in our description,
actually reading it is a whole other experience.
The tale is darkly humorous, almost allegorical,
but at the same time shot through with a sense
of grander themes lurking beneath the surface,
just out of reach.
For Kafka, it was the first good thing he
ever wrote, the moment when he metamorphosed
from a man who did some writing to an actual
writer.
That same year, he would sit down and write
a much more literal tale of metamorphosis,
about Gregor Samsa, who woke up one morning
from uneasy dreams to find himself changed
in his bed into a monstrous vermin.
But while The Metamorphosis would be the only
work in Kafka’s lifetime that sold well,
and would remain his best-known story, it
was The Judgement that the author considered
his masterpiece.
At the top of the first page, he scrawled
a hasty dedication.
“To Miss Felice Bauer.”
A Little Woman
When you look at this period of Franz Kafka’s
life, it’s remarkable just how closely his
work parallels his relationship with Bauer.
Remarkable, because the two barely ever met.
Although they constantly sent one another
letters, Kafka constantly turned down chances
to meet his “beloved” in the flesh.
He was too busy at work.
His writing required attention.
He had a headache and was washing his hair.
It’s been suggested the paradox at the heart
of Kafka’s life is that he thought he wanted
to be left completely alone, but secretly
craved human contact.
Or maybe the other way around.
Still, he evidently longed for company enough
to eventually propose to Bauer.
By letter, naturally.
On May 31, 1914, the couple finally met face
to face again at their engagement party.
Surrounded by his family and Felice’s, Kafka
felt nothing but bottomless misery.
Before three months were out, the two had
mutually broken off their engagement.
Although they’d wind up getting back together,
you can see clearly the effect this rollercoaster
had on Kafka’s work.
1914 was the year he abandoned Amerika with
just one chapter left to write.
It’s the year he wrote In the Penal Colony,
a grim, cruel story that’s even darker than
The Judgement.
It’s also the year he started his most famous
novel of all: The Trial.
The story of a man, Joseph K, who is charged
with a crime without ever knowing what that
crime is, The Trial is a landmark of absurd,
alienated fiction.
For chapter after chapter, Joseph K tries
desperately to find out what he’s guilty
of, while uncovering all sorts of bizarre
figures, grotesque tortures, and strange sexualized
rituals happening in secret rooms.
By the end, we still don’t know what crime
he committed.
Because it’s so ambiguous, The Trial has
come to symbolize a million things to a million
readers.
For some, Joseph K’s crime is simply that
he’s human.
For others, it’s that he’s a Jew living
in an anti-Semitic world.
Others see in it a premonition of the Soviet
Union’s secret police.
In the 1960s, Orson Welles made a film version
that hinted Joseph K was targeted for being
gay.
In short, The Trial is one of those books
that’s so universal everyone can see their
experiences reflected in it.
But not during Kafka’s lifetime.
In 1915, the reclusive writer slipped his
manuscript of The Trial into a desk drawer.
He never looked at it again.
The following year, Kafka and Felice Bauer
spent nearly two weeks in the spa town of
Marienbad, attempting to patch things up.
It worked and, on July 12, 1917, the two got
engaged all over again.
This time they even started making plans to
live together in Prague.
But 1917 was also the year Franz Kafka got
some life changing news.
Or maybe life ending might be more accurate.
That year, he was diagnosed with tuberculosis.
In the early years of the 20th Century, tuberculosis
was a death sentence.
The disease killed Andrew Jackson, Jane Austen,
George Orwell, and was once estimated to have
killed 15% of all people who had ever lived.
And it would kill Franz Kafka too.
In December, 1917, a sick and depressed Kafka
broke off his engagement to Felice for a second
time.
For Felice, this was the last straw.
She cut off contact with her former fiancee,
found a more stable man to marry.
The part of Kafka that wished he could be
completely alone had gotten what it wanted.
Kafka’s Judgement
On October 28, 1918, the Austro-Hungarian
Empire gave one last groan and collapsed.
As WWI drew to a close, Prague found itself
no longer under Germanic rule, but part of
a new republic composed of Czechs and Slovaks.
At his workplace, Kafka was taken for questioning
along with all the other German speakers to
see if they supported the new regime.
Those who were actively against it were fired.
But we can only imagine that Kafka didn’t
care all that much about that stuff.
He had more important things to worry about.
In early 1919, Kafka was taking some time
away from Prague in a boarding house when
he happened to meet Julie Wohryzek.
At only 28, she was nearly 8 years his junior.
But still, the two fell to talking, and bonded
over a shared love of Yiddish theatre and
risque humor.
By the time they both returned to Prague,
Kafka had decided to marry her.
As firm bases for a lasting relationship go,
there are probably better ones.
But still, Wohryzek agreed, and an excited
Kafka ran to tell his parents.
At which point Hermann Kafka detonated like
a pink, flabby bomb.
If Hermann disapproved of his useless son
in general, then you’d have to invent whole
new ways of measuring disapproval to understand
how he felt about this whirlwind marriage.
For the next few months, Kafka’s father
harangued him.
Bullied him.
Browbeat him over his plans.
At first, Kafka tried to stand his ground.
But a lifetime of belittling had crushed his
self esteem down to nothing.
In November, 1919, Kafka broke off his engagement
with Wohryzek.
Not long after, Kafka left Prague again and
checked himself into the same guesthouse where
he’d met his second fiancee.
There, he sat down and composed a letter to
his father, finally saying all the things
he was too scared to say to his face.
Running at 45 pages, Kafka’s Letter to His
Father was his own judgement on the tyrant
who’d raised him.
What’s remarkable today is just how clear-eyed
it was.
Kafka was at pains to stress he understood
his father’s position; that he knew dragging
yourself up from a working class background
was not an easy thing to do.
While Hermann may be the villain in our story
today, it’s worth remembering that no-one
in real life is purely evil.
Hermann Kafka was just a man who’d been
taught by the snobbish society he lived in
that only being loud, brash, and angry would
get him noticed, get him respected.
It’s just a shame he felt those qualities
should apply to his parenting, too.
At the end of the letter, Kafka wrote that
he hoped his honesty would open the door to
an improved relationship between the two of
them.
But then, shy and insecure to the last, he
chickened out of posting it.
The next year, possibly as a rebound, Kafka
started a relationship with one of his translators
in Vienna, a Czech girl called Milena Jesenska.
But when November again rolled around, Kafka
abruptly broke off the relationship.
Once again, the twisted version of Hermann
sitting in the center of Kafka’s mind had
condemned the writer to a living death.
A Hunger Artist
Kurt Vonnegut once wrote that Kafka’s stories
exemplify a certain type of fiction, in which
the protagonist starts miserable, only to
see things get continuously worse.
The same was true of Kafka’s life.
Fair warning: there’s going to be no heroic
moment in this tale.
No emotional climax where Kafka manages to
finally stand up to Hermann, get the girl,
and ride off into the Prague sunset.
No, instead, we’re going to watch a miserable
man’s life get continuously worse, until
it all ends the only way it can.
By 1922, it was obvious what that ending would
be.
That year, Kafka’s tuberculosis got so bad
he was finally forced to retire from work.
In one sense, this was actually a good thing.
Kafka had long wished he could devote himself
to writing full time, and now there was nothing
stopping him.
That January, he began writing his last great
work, The Castle.
The story of a man known only as K, The Castle
follows K’s attempts to meet the authorities
presiding over a snowbound town, only to discover
his path blocked at every turn.
Today, The Castle is seen as Kafka’s most
mature novel.
But Kafka himself didn’t feel this way.
On September 11, 1922, Kafka wrote to Max
Brod to inform him he’d given up on the
story and would never return to it.
Yet it wouldn’t be fair to say Kafka had
also given up on life.
The next year, the sick man moved to Berlin.
One day, he booked himself a trip to the resort
town of Muritz to try and help his TB.
It was while on the shore that Kafka met Dora
Diamant.
A 19-year old socialist, Dora was 20 years
Kafka’s junior.
But she was also fiercely intelligent, with
hard-edged political beliefs, and a passionate
support for Zionism that chimed with Kafka’s
own feelings.
At Muritz, the two talked and talked until,
finally, it seemed only natural that Dora
would return to Berlin with Kafka.
But don’t assume this was some great autumn
romance.
By 1923, Kafka was so sick that Dora’s role
was more that of a live-in nurse than a lover.
He was also stony broke.
Hyperinflation had gripped Weimar Germany,
wiping out Kafka’s pension.
By November, 1923, the pair were reduced to
using candles to heat their food.
Still, Dora’s influence was causing Kafka
to feel a tiny ray of optimism for the first
time in years.
He even began making plans to move to Palestine.
But this is the story of Franz Kafka.
And there was no way fate was going to grant
him such happiness.
In early 1924, Kafka’s health finally collapsed.
Forced by his doctor to check into a hospital,
Kafka selected a sanitorium outside Vienna.
Then, gloomily, he left Berlin for good.
As he made his way towards his final resting
place, Kafka found time to stop in Prague.
Just long enough to give Max Brod his unfinished
manuscripts of The Trial, Amerika, and The
Castle and ask him to burn them.
In late March, 1924, Kafka arrived at the
Vienna sanitorium for treatment.
Three months later, on June 3, he died of
his illness.
On his deathbed, he wried Dora Diamant’s
father, asking for permission to marry her.
Dora’s father curtly replied “no.”
At the time he passed away, Kafka was a man
whose life story seemed to be that of a sickly
insurance lawyer who was unlucky in love,
and never did anything of note.
His writing was known only by a tiny circle
of Prague intellectuals, and even they’d
only seen the published stuff.
The bulk of his work had been seen only by
Kafka, who died having made his best friend
promise to burn it all.
Luckily for posterity, that best friend just
happened to be a consummate liar.
The Man Who Re-Appeared
Many years later, Max Brod would reflect on
his final meeting with Kafka, and offer this
explanation.
According to Brod, Kafka knew his best friend
would never burn his manuscripts.
If he’d really wanted them destroyed, he
would’ve asked Dora or Hermann, who’d
have probably burned them with relish.
By asking Brod, Kafka was in effect asking
the one person he knew would ignore his wishes
and try to publish his novels.
And that’s exactly what Brod did.
All through the rest of 1924, Brod diligently
organized Kafka’s papers, sifting the piles
of notes into chapters, grouping them by theme,
figuring out how they might slot into a wider
novel.
By early 1925, he was finished.
That April, Brod used his literary connections
to get The Trial published.
It was well enough received in Europe that
The Castle followed a year later, and Amerika
a year after that.
By 1930, all three of Kafka’s novels, plus
his collected short stories, were available
for European intellectuals to marvel over.
Come 1937, the first English editions even
began to appear.
But it would be another decade before the
spark really lit.
After WWII, publishing houses in America began
to take a chance on this long-dead author
they were hearing so much about.
It was this more than anything that cemented
Kafka’s reputation.
For whatever reason, postwar America was primed
and ready for Kafka.
His popularity exploded.
People like Nabokov sang his praises.
Below the border, southern American writers
like Gabriel Garcia Marquez and Jorge Luis
Borges devoured his works.
The rest, as they say, is history.
Today, Kafka is one of a handful of writers
almost everyone has heard of, an author as
recognizable as George Orwell, Edgar Allen
Poe, or H.P.
Lovecraft.
But while all these men were known as writers
in their day - even the underappreciated Lovecraft
- Kafka is maybe the only one who rose from
complete obscurity, and brought such complex,
unique riches with him.
If you go to Prague’s new Jewish cemetery
today, you can still see the shared grave
where Kafka and Hermann lie for eternity,
side by side.
But while Kafka may not have been able to
escape his abusive father even in death, he
has now escaped Hermann’s judgement.
Because history remembers him not as a disappointment,
but as Franz Kafka: the writer who changed
the way we see
the world.